the gyro can experience I think some
people have the burden of intelligence
and what I mean by that is that they're
really smart and they see a lot of
people around them that are silly and
they experience that so often that they
get weary and they get they get you know
that they sort of get rigid in their
belief that their opinions are correct
because they dismiss most of the people
that are around them mm-hmm cuz you're
on a bunch of dummies if you really
smart guy or smart girl it's hard it's
hard to maintain a good perception of
what things are and what things aren't
when you're the smartest person in the
room you kind of never want to be the
smartest person in the room yeah and
also yes and also believing that you are
yeah no way excludes you from including
other people who are also smarter than
everybody in the room well Sonny maybe
not even smarter which I said but I
never sided by an ideology their
perspective isn't dimmed right yeah yes
they see things clearly which is I think
one of the most underrated forms of
intelligence like there's all this
intelligence and solving mathematical
problems yeah right social intelligence
but this heart there's there's a bunch
of different kinds of intelligence
absolutely be able to see through the
[ __ ] is is it intelligence and some
people don't have it yeah no absolutely
and I think that you know at the same
time wanting to help someone see that
angle is also an important thing so if
you're like if you're someone who's like
oh [ __ ] like let's say it says maybe
you're maybe you're trained in tactical
awareness right and you I just have a
different way of being in a room where
you sit about all that stuff and the
situation arises where like potentially
something dangerous could happen or
whatever then being able to explain that
idea and that type of awareness so that
someone can see that is also possible
like sharing it they may not get it to
the extent that you do but they at least
you've included it in their viewpoint
yeah maybe well people that are soldiers
they do have a weird where men are in
the room since my friend Andy stump he's
uh always sneaking up on me he says you
got no situational awareness yeah yeah
like bring a crowd what am I supposed to
just constantly on 360 looking for
danger
I mean yeah that's what he's saying but
that's because you seal you know yeah
how they look at they look at things a
whole lot difference how you stay alive
exactly yeah
I think one of the things it's super
important for people to recognize and
helps them open their mind up to other
opinions is that even if they favor
themselves very highly that competitive
thing of comparing your intellect and
your reason to other people it's very
limiting yes then instead of worrying
about yourself if you're smart just be
smart yeah but they just appreciate
other intelligences you just just get
into talking to them this isn't that's
my thoughts on it instead of being
competitive with them get into trying to
find out how they they work because
there's a lot of different humans on
this planet and we have this egocentric
position almost everybody does that
there are at least better at one thing
than other people are or they know some
more about one thing that other people
do and it's a weird competitive thing
that people get involved in it's been
it's stupid like yeah you should
recognize that it's awesome to have cool
people around you that are like really
smart and interested in weird [ __ ] and
you're intelligent and inspiring you
almost envy their their creativity those
are nicely important people to have in
your life but when people get they feel
weird about comparing themselves to the
other person because they come up on
favor and sing in security exactly
that's where I see that with a lot of
guys guys puff up chest and start you
know comparing like how much their house
is cost like she's like literally doing
stuff that you're like oh we're still
doing this like to Tipton to my mind I'm
like oh [ __ ] you guys aren't aware of it
like a way that I yeah you guys are
doing some 1990 [ __ ] here yeah because
it's like I know cuz like either they're
like doing an act yeah you know which
I'm always hoping and I'm always okay
that's why there's disbelief when it
really is what it is I'm like oh [ __ ] oh
that's best for real that's actually the
thing it's weird right yeah it is a
little it's a little weird I mean some
people have a lack of cool people around
them too that's a real problem
yes he's stuck in Ashe it's like a good
tomato plant is not going to grow in the
[ __ ] Sonora
desert all right there's no nutrients
there it's too bright it's the sun's too
hot it's not the right climate
[Applause]